Sequencer is Unreal Engine 5's editor for creating and editing linear animations, but
it can also be used for so much more than that.
You can actually use Sequencer for gameplay events to help you generate movies or promotional
items.
It can be used pretty much like an offline renderer or in a real time capacity.
Let's pop into the editor now and see more about how this tool works.
First off, to create and work with Sequencer, we need to create something called a level
sequence.
To do that, there's a number of different ways.
We can right-click inside of here and we can come down to our, I believe it is under
Cinematics, we can create a level sequence or animation sequence or a template sequence,
we can come up here to the sequences up here and we can either add a level sequence or
add a level sequence with a shots track.
The difference between them is this.
A level sequence will allow us to have one shot, but a level sequence with a shots track
will allow us to have a level sequence with multiple cameras inside of it.
Let's say that we know we're going to be using five or six cameras because we have five or
six camera cuts.
Instead of setting those all up for us one by one, we can click the add level sequence
with shots to have those five shots already created for us.
For now though, I'm just going to select this add level sequence and we're going to call
this LS underscore example.
When I do that, you're going to notice something a little bit different happens.
All of a sudden the sequence opens up and if I hit control space, we can see it's right
there.
We can close sequencer just by hitting that X and then open it anytime by just clicking
on the sequence to open it up.
One of the cool things about sequencer is we can add transforms or rotations or pretty
much anything that we want just as long as we see one of these little key frame.
Key property can actually be key framed if it has one of those little diamonds next to
it.
Let's just take a quick look at the editor itself.
Across the top here, we're going to have our main toolbar.
This is our actors that we want to put in here.
There's our save, there's our browse.
This creates a new camera and sets it to the new camera cut.
This allows us to render things out if we want to take a pre-rendered video or something
like that.
This opens up our blueprints, these are our actions and there's a whole bunch of different
things inside of here.
These are our view options, we have our playback options and then our key frame and our snapping
as well as our playback speed and our curve editor.
Now, to add something to sequence, what you can do is select it inside the viewport and
then come here to add and you can add, like we can add the new logo, we can look for it
or we can add selected from the content browser.
For me, I'm just going to add this new UEE logo and you can see as soon as I do that,
it adds a track.
This works just the same as any linear based editor.
We put down key frames and then we move this over like this and then we maybe go like that
and you can see here it's automatically actually going to make that key frame motion for me.
There we go.
To work with one of these properties, it's the same way.
Let's come up here to our, maybe we'll do our transform.
We'll do something like, I don't know, add a key frame
and actually it's in auto mode so I don't even need to add one but you can see here it's
doing that.
We can also take multiple objects.
So let me just come here and we're going to go add a point light.
There we go.
Where is that?
Let's hit G so we can kind of see where that is.
There we go.
So let's just add that, add a sequencer, add our point light.
And then we can do something like our intensity is set to 8 but we come here, maybe we set
it to like 80.
So you know, maybe we set it back to 8.
There we go.
So it's kind of like making a little, let's move this a little bit closer to the ground.
There we go, something like that.
So just showing you can have multiple different actors in the same sequence all going off.
Now to actually play this sequence inside of your project, you will need to set up a
little bit of blueprint logic just to fire off the sequence when the level plays.
But other than that, sequences are a fantastic way to create any type of interactive cinematic
or content or linear based content that you wish and have it rendered all in real time,
output to video and it can really cut down on production times, especially again if you're
using this for any type of linear based media.